a very concerning report from the CDC
indicating record levels of sadness in
teenage girls this report says the teens
are quote engulfed in violence and
Trauma with nearly three and five
feeling persistent sadness Mary Jane
beliesza joins us now Mary Jane you
spent the day talking with parents about
this issue
I did and this survey was released
Monday and these numbers are just some
of the mental health Trends in high
schoolers that have peaked within teen
girls in just the past decade I spoke
with the therapist on what parents
should look out for and how they can
help
I knew something was wrong is when they
stopped talking when I started getting
the fine everything's good fine Mindy
laforte a mother of three says she makes
sure to check in with her kids to
discuss topics of mental health abuse
and thoughts of suicide my middle
daughter has had to deal with it the
worst though personally last year we had
to pull her out of her high school and
change high schools because she was
actually a victim of
all the stuff that you read about in
those articles and in those studies a
youth risk behavior survey from the CDC
shows 30 percent of girls seriously
considered attempting suicide an 18
experienced sexual violence Sasha decana
a licensed marriage and family counselor
says she wasn't surprised by the study's
Numbers the part that was most troubling
for me was the increase the substantial
increase of sexual assault against young
women decana says most people who
experience sexual abuse are from people
we know reporting it makes it that much
harder when we're isolated or simply
scared she also says those with
depression and stress may see an
increase in physical aggression or
self-harm so how can parents talk with
kids about these hard topics kids know
that this is happening what they don't
know is where they can be powerful in
protecting themselves and that is our
role to teach them as parents and people
who love them leforte knows while it
will take time it does take a whole
Community when it comes to getting your
kids help it's been a struggle and it's
been help from everybody all of her
friends her community
other CDC school-based survey results
are expected to be released in April
which covers other issues like diet and
exercise